sustainable investing is sort of an
umbrella term it's been a breakout year
for environmental social and governance
issues known better as esg 2020 was
really an inflection for esg and as a
result
it's become a mainstream topic that kind
of subgroup called esg is really by far
the biggest area within sustainable
investing which in just the past few
years
has gone from nothing to more than 30
trillion dollars in assets under
management sustainability
it's more than an environmental issue as
everybody seeks to sort of invest their
money in a way that they believe at
least is more aligned with their values
i believe there will be a future that
all investments are going to be looked
through sustainability that's why i
really talk to our people about just
four words higher returns lower carbon
the key question that we've been looking
at this year is how much is sustainable
investing helping the world making
capitalism more sustainable and how much
is it making money for wall street the
securities and exchange commission has
come up with a regulatory agenda to
bring in more regulation as far as esg
disclosures are concerned you've got to
pull back the top layers and look more
deeply there is a threat of greenwashing
and it needs to be monitored it needs to
be dealt with in that process we decided
that we wanted to look back at the
origins of sustainable investing i found
a book that was published in 1991
dedicated in part to these two obscure
financiers called robert schwartz and
robert zevin
i set out to find out as much as i could
about these two men their investment
practices how they were viewed on wall
street and also to find them if i
possibly could
[Music]
robert schwartz died in 2006 but i did
find
an extraordinary documentary decades old
that had been made about him
innovating these practices by a
filmmaker who spent a ton of time with
him and followed him around
across the country i didn't grow up
intending to be an investment advisor
any more than i did a fireman or a
policeman
business not as usual is
an 18-minute film
that
i
recorded
on 16 millimeter film when films were
really films
in the
1980s and the 1990s
at that time
i was considerably younger than i am now
and i came upon
people
who
i discovered
were
using their work in ways that i had
never heard of
25 years ago i realized that a strategy
of directing investments according to
progressive values could become a
forceful instrument for social change
robert schwartz grew up during the
depression the world's richest and
supposedly soundest economy perished and
small business was strangled by the
great depression he was born in 1917
so he was coming of age
during the time when
america was
really at its lowest financially with
millions of people unemployed
with millions of people going hungry
this had a lifelong impact on him i did
go through the depression as a teenager
and
keenly aware of the problems of poverty
and unemployment
robert schwartz was a senior level
official at the u.s treasury department
when world war ii began and so he
enrolled in the u.s marine corps and he
was sent to the pacific
after the war he went back to the
treasury department where he worked in
the international section we should
remember that practically every issue
which we face today
from high taxes
to the shameful mess in korea
is inextricably interwoven
with the communist issue sadly after the
war there was also kind of a series of
witch hunts that began in the us
going after so-called communists or
leftists who were inside the u.s
government apparently every time anybody
says anything against anybody working
for santa mccarthy
[Music]
it swept up hollywood it swept up
literature it swept up washington dc and
the highest powered corners of the us
government especially the treasury
department and the pentagon this body is
improperly constituted it is a kangaroo
court it does not have my respect it has
my utmost content robert schwartz got
caught up in this because he was a
leftist he was incredibly progressive
for his time and he had to give up his
career and his his livelihood and the
future of his family even was in
jeopardy because he didn't know how or
if he would ever be able to make a
living again
it's
created
a
lifelong desire
on his part
to
challenge
established authorities
it also led to
him
wanting to do in whatever ways that he
could
use
the next steps that were at that time
unknown
to
again pursue
what he believed strongly in
i was put in a position of really having
to retire from the treasury department
and started life over again back in new
york with the amalgamated bank he
finally found a bank on wall street that
was a pretty unique bank and a pretty
innovative bank and also a pretty
progressive bank it was called the
amalgamated bank and it was set up by a
textile workers union that represented
european jews who were fleeing europe in
the 20th century and coming to work in
one of the toughest industries which was
the textile the garmin industry and the
bank was founded by the union as a safe
repository for the workers earnings for
their pensions for their welfare funds
but also as a way to provide credit to
them so they could start the american
dream and own a home and have access to
finance that could change their lives
and the lives of their families
[Music]
when robert went into the amalgamated
bank he discovered something pretty
extraordinary he was responsible for
about a billion dollars in assets uh
that the bank had which is a huge amount
back then and he discovered that a
significant amount of these funds were
invested by a union essentially
in companies that were anti-union that
were breaking strikes that refused to
negotiate with their workers that were
even engaged in sporting violence
against their own workers on picket
lines and he thought that the bank
should definitely alter its investment
practices to not
support companies that were engaged in
unfair labor practices and this was
really
a first
for anyone
robert schwartz believed
that
it was possible both to
do
well and to do good
portfolios for clients may avoid
military contractors exclude nuclear
power destroyers of the environment
union busters
and business in south africa
to replace those companies i seek
innovative companies meeting social
needs he was not after
maximum profits
he was after
maximum profits that would fit
with
what he believed and what most
importantly his clients believed had his
clients not believed in that
my guess
is that
rather than change his principles he
would have dropped those clients
i had a call from washington while
robert schwartz was building his
practice around these principles another
investment advisor another economist
this one trained at harvard was building
a very similar business for clients
starting with his family in boston
i started investing
for myself
when
my parents began
giving me stock in the company they
encouraged me my father anyway
encouraged me to sell it and invest it
which i did i must have been
extraordinarily lucky because i invested
all my money in only one or two stocks
and i just had two or three or four
big winners i said great so by the time
i'm
30 i'll be a millionaire just from
investing
and did that happen no
[Laughter]
it did not happen
i started an organization called resist
designed to
deliver support for individuals mostly
for civilians who
use passive resistance
tax refusal whatever to oppose the war
and a year later
i started the united states servicemen's
fund
which
had the
more important ambition and more useful
ambition of supporting servicemen
and women who oppose the war so in the
day i'm
teaching
and the weekends
investing
and in the evenings i'm knocking on
people's doors
and going and visiting them to raise
money
for these causes
but a few of them would say what
a person with your politics you're in
the investment business i'd love to have
you manage my money they would say but
i don't want to own weapons
manufacturers i don't want to own
people who make
napalm i don't want to own people who do
strip mining i don't want to own
companies in south africa so it was the
investors really who brought the idea to
the investors who brought the idea to me
and it was i was very reluctant and very
skeptical and it took about five years
of success
to convince me that i had been wrong and
that
this didn't cost anything
more than seven thousand anti-vietnam
war demonstrators parade near the los
angeles hotel where president johnson
attends a democratic fundraising dinner
the civil rights movement and the
vietnam war both created similar
momentum
for some really clever activists who
realized that they could use money and
boycott specifically
to channel their activism into capital
and to hold back capital or divest from
companies that or other actors that
weren't supporting civil rights or were
supporting the vietnam war
probably the first really high profile
war contractor that was targeted in at
least modern u.s history was the dow
chemical company and the dow chemical
company was manufacturing
napalm for the u.s military for its use
in vietnam
nearly 400 000
tons of napalm were dropped on vietnam
it was estimated within a decade from
1963 to 1973. so the dow chemical
company which was making napalm and
profiting from napalm became a main
target of the investment activist
community which was really coming
together for the first time
the boycotts against dao did start to
take a toll and they proved effective
publicizing the destructive role of
military contractors caused many on wall
street to oppose the war
this led more legitimacy to the peace
movement and helped bring an end to the
war which claimed 50 000 american lives
and over one million vietnamese after
dow chemical the movement really started
to grow and it grew beyond labor
standards and a main new target of
activists and activist investors
became
every major u.s company that was doing
business in south africa south africa
was run by a white minority regime and
was under attack and under pressure from
virtually all corners of the world and
it was really the activist community
joining up with people like robert
schwartz and robert seven who started to
push the divestment movement in the
united states the exclusion of the
companies in south africa from the s p
500
has resulted in better performance both
robert schwartz and robert seven were
surprised
when they ran the numbers their
strategies of not investing in companies
that were doing things that they and
their investors found
horrible was actually working out
incredibly well for their investors and
for them do you remember if there was a
moment when you really
thought this this could be a good thing
i'm not sure i remember some some light
going off but years later i did some
research
about the effects of
these screens and and and proved that
the restrictions had no effect on
on results and many other people did the
same research but didn't tell anybody
about it
because they didn't want to embarrass
their clients who were opposed to it
eliminating
each whole sector of the s p 500 doesn't
make any difference over 5 10 15 20
years you still get the same result
which is kind of amazing and
counterintuitive it's now a widely
accepted
idea that all these restrictions do not
make any difference divestment should
not be ruled out on financial grounds
the final consideration is not its
effect on your investment portfolio but
its effect on apartheid
i think the most extraordinary thing
that i found in looking at these two men
robert schwartz and robert zevin was how
they just flew in the face of everything
that was happening politically this was
the reagan thatcher era everything that
was happening on wall street everything
that was happening in the city of london
was the exact opposite of what these two
peacenik economists were pushing as
investment advisors and and they were
viewed
somewhat openly at times with hostility
by other investment advisors by other
people in the business that they were in
almost never did this oh that's very
interesting um i almost always just said
oh
that's almost that's impossible or that
must be very difficult or
why why would you do that
it always seemed like like a foreign
land to me anyway so the impact on me
was was nil basically i i just kept
plotting along my own path
the practice of social investment that i
and a few others began 25 years ago
has garnered increasing acceptance and
respect with the huge amounts of money
available for productive application
investment decisions can profoundly
shape public discussion and social
conditions socially responsible
investing is a powerful vehicle for
pointing the way to a more just and
humane society
there are still a handful of niche funds
and niche investment firms
that really focus on the kinds of
principles that robert schwartz and
robert 7 put into practice but in the
past couple years what's really changed
is wall street has capitalized on this
demand by investors
to want to make the world a better place
but it's done it mostly through
marketing and underneath that marketing
are some rather dubious claims about
making the world a better place
we're seeing transformative changes in
almost every sector of the economy and
that's very very encouraging but
investors who want to participate in
this have to take care
to identify the risk of green washing
success was the mother of defeat somehow
i think some of the original pioneers
were actually the instigators of
deciding that it really wasn't socially
responsible investing anymore it was
esg environment social and governance
investing which
to my way of thinking was was
was taking something that was a social
movement
and that was intimately connected to
people who weren't investors and didn't
own stock but were struggling to make a
living or to end a war or to escape from
a war it somehow threw all those people
out and it said now we're a niche
product
it's not just wall street it's
capitalism it always finds some way to
repackage an idea so that it's
profitable and
mass producible
and
that's going to be hard to overcome
all of the really groundbreaking things
that these two men did in finance are
really what led us to this extraordinary
moment today where this has become a
multi-trillion dollar business on wall
street
the problem for people who've invested
their money in these strategies and in
these funds especially in the united
states is that fundamentally the largest
funds don't address the key questions
that people believe are being addressed
by the funds in fact some of the biggest
ones
actually can contribute to making things
even worse
[Music]
[Music]
you